uh well the business environment has uh
changed uh totally uh over the summer uh
we've gone from a situation where our
members uh on balance uh were much more
optimistic about future prospects for
the wider uk economy
to a situation sadly where just slightly
more people are pessimistic about
the uk economy over the next 12 months
than are optimistic
and these are typically small and
medium-sized businesses 85
outside london uh institute of directors
members so these are the individuals
actually leading their firms they're
saying that their
costs are expected uh to rise to a
greater extent than their revenues um
in the 12 months coming up and
our sense is that this is attributed to
a number of factors
there's the widely publicized supply
chain problems that are affecting all
different sectors of of the economy and
of course just as our poll went into the
field in early september the government
said that it would be raising employers
national insurance which is basically a
flat tax on employing people regardless
of what your uh profits are
are doing so we think that that's
probably had an effect as well
yes i mean anecdotally talking to a lot
of business leaders over the last week
it really feels to me as so that was the
moment sentiment started to sound it was
these national insurance increases
uh yes i mean we really feel it's quite
an extraordinary time to be raising the
cost of employing people just as the
furlough scheme comes to an end and when
there are already sort of supply issues
in the labor market
we we know that there are staff
shortages our members are telling us
that they're having uh staff shortages
around a half of iod members are
reporting that to us and they're very
concerned about it and interestingly um
whilst there is a bit of a sort of
pandemic and brexit effect uh the
majority of those firms that say they
are experiencing shortages of uh staff
are saying that this is a a long term
sort of endemic problem
and they're very much looking looking to
government i think and there's a budget
obviously coming up in a month or so
that
they're looking to government to
to to do something about it and so i
think what
today's data shows is is that this is
very real in terms of um how businesses
are feeling that the environment has
changed um we have definitely no longer
got the sort of post-pandemic euphoria
that we that we saw in in the summer in
in fact firms are feeling the same about
the economy as they did in the height of
the third lockdown um which is slightly
concerning and why does this matter well
because if you think that uh the sort of
overall wider economic outlook is
looking a bit cloudy then of course
you're less likely to feel confident
enough to invest
um to put your firm's retained profits
or your shareholders cash into investing
for a sort of medium-term plan and
that's that's not good for future
prospects and not good for government
tax revenues in the future either
well kitty i mean you're a former
economic secretary to the treasury on in
the last labour government what would
you be doing in the government's shoes i
mean they've obviously got a colossal
budget deficit borrowing has gone
through the roof i mean they have to do
something to try and restore order to
the public finances don't they
absolutely and nobody disputes that what
has happened over the last few months
however
is that
tax revenues have come in at a faster
rate than was anticipated at the time of
the last budget
and of course it's
a rising corporation tax plus a hike to
national insurance that is currently uh
doing the heavy lifting in terms of
uh how the debt consolidation uh plan is
expected to
to operate so i think i think the
message from the latest economic data
is perhaps the government are slightly
kind of overshot in what it's doing um
and it's starting to have a very real
effect on the economy so maybe time to
sort of re recalibrate and think again
about how they're going to
consolidate finances into the medium
term